the Prime Minister of Croatia the
Buddhist Minister for agriculture is the
president of the German Farmers
Association mr. president of German food
and drink industries mr. senator burr
and mr. geek
ladies and gentlemen minor dominum
Herren liberal and realtor as is mere in
a grocer area on ish Froy image there
how it here MIT ihnen this Avista land
with shaft leash a master of the green
and warhead so evening and through in an
sprechen sued even the land width shaft
lock mere shown immerser am Harrison and
mich fear belong the land filter and
Suzette's an is mere ina grosser Florida
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this is privileged
to participate to the Green Week here in
Berlin and intership international event
that gathers all the farmers and all the
key players of the food chain from the
public and the private sector from
Germany Europe and the world we started
the Green Week in Berlin but in our
political debate we start discussion
about the green future green years green
decades and green century the European
Green Deal is a big is a priority for
the European Commission is a big
challenge for all society for all
economy and also for the agriculture
European Green Deal can be chance for
the European farmers but there is one
condition farmers should be treated as a
part of solution not as a problem for
solution but the part of solution
[Applause]
European farmers needs appropriate
support for their new obligations for
their new tasks because of European
Green Deal and this is a very important
issue for the future Common Agricultural
Policy I'd like to thank for Minister
Yulia click nur for her initiative
together with the French and Spanish
ministers of Agriculture declaration
last month presenting proposal how to
improve Common Agricultural Policy and
how to strengthen the budget which is
very important for achieving the goals
of European Green Deal for the
contribution of Agriculture to the
European Green Deal thank you very much
for this declaration which is a good
base for the further discussion for the
improvement of the proposal from the
Commission which we have on the table
ladies and gentlemen very important word
innovation Green Week is opportunity not
only for the promotion of the
agriculture products but also to
exchange knowledge to exchange good
practices to exchange new knowledge
about the new technologies agriculture
should be more innovative but also the
Common Agricultural Policy policy should
be more innovative we propose the reform
of the agriculture policy more
flexibility for Member States more
opportunities for flexibility for to use
instrument which are appropriate to the
special special situation in the Member
States but we should continue our
discussion to improve this proposal
security very important work
our farmers European farmers and sure
food supply security for 500 million
European citizens but we should ensure
security for our farmers we should oops
we should remember that there is a lot
of Reds for European farming there is
the for example that during one decade
we lost four million farms in European
Union the numbers of farms was reduced
from 14 million to the 210 million one
day 1,000 farm was disappeared this is
very big problem generation and renewal
also the problems which mr. rope which
said that international trade
we should better protect our farmers the
same standards for the importer than for
the European producers European farmers
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen as a commissioner
this is my first presence here I'm very
happy to be here I'd like to promise you
that I will do everything which is
possible from my position to help
farmers to support farmers and to
improve the European policy to create
better for for our farmers I this is my
feeling as a politician I have my
personal experience I am NOT a farmer
this is not my current profession I was
born in the family farmers family in
Poland I know what is the hard work in
the farms and this is the reason that I
understand well the farmers problems and
farmers emotions ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to wish you successful
promotion of your products successful
exchange of knowledge good practices and
I wish for all of us
successful effective cooperation to make
European agriculture more competitive
more innovative more friendly for
environment and climate and to make
European agriculture policy more
friendly for farmers thank you very much
[Applause]